et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec gamal à bina cofondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques bonsoir
gamma d'amina merci d'être avec nous
face aux ja gariel à vos côtés
secrétaire national de la république
souveraine pour la laïcité bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous on a
entendu donc le ministre intérieur pas
content du tout voilà qui rappelle que
cette fédération a refusé de signer la
charte des principes de l'islam et une
clos sa critique en disant vivement que
tout le monde ouvre les yeux et que la
loi séparatistes ne soient bientôt votée
et promulguée malavida avec cette fois
séparatisme ça n'aurait pas été possible
la construction de cette mosquée je jure
sensible aujourd'hui qu'on observe
question islam de france
évidemment s'il part d'une loi qui n'est
pas encore votée ce n'aurait pas été
possible parce que c'est tout est très
restrictive mais mais a contrario
l'alsace-moselle text l'excellent the
lorraine est un territoire allemand on a
à peu près 50 ans et spécificités
régionales a autorisé financement des
cultes des quatre cultes le culte
israélites le réformer le plus tôt
luthériens et de calvinistes donc le
problème c'est que on peut interdire à
un culte bénéficient de cette spéciale
dans une région ce que les autres ont
droit d'avoir ce qui est pas normal
alors c'est vrai qu'on va parler du fond
aussi du débat parce qu'il ya eu
d'autres critiques mais faouzia gariel
effectivement la loi sur le concordat
autorise qui de deux subventions en
alsace ça plaise ou non est ce que vous
vous trouvez cela choquant oui dans la
mesure où ce n'est pas la construction
de la mosquée et la subvention qui lui
est accordée qui ils sont c'est plutôt
le fait que cette mosquée comme bien
d'autres mosquées d'ailleurs en france
soit sous le contrôle du millet golis le
milieu risque est une organisation
islamique islamique sous le contrôle de
la diana
c'est le ministre des cultes en turquie
et le contrôle direct de la carte et
donc elle est au service d'un soft power
erdogan bien d'accord pour étendre son
influence sont toutes les communautés
musulmanes de france en prônant en
soutenant un islam conservateur
patriarcal le mélies gorille qui y siège
d'ailleurs ou qui est membre statutaire
du conseil français du culte musulman a
refusé de signer la charte proposée par
le président emmanuel macron pour les
principes donc de 10 thèmes de france et
pour cause ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
la laïcité
ils sont favorables à ce que les femmes
porte une burqa bon un voile peu importe
que les femmes n'occupent pas certains
métiers et il se sent la turquie s'est
retirée donc de là la charte du conseil
de l'europe de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes qu'ils
avaient signé en 2011
au prétexte que ces chartes finalement
sur la cohésion familiale quoi donc on
finance effectivement une mosquée sous
contrôle d'une organisation islamique
l'islam politique
louis ligue au russe ne s'en cache pas
il le dit lui même très proche donc des
frères musulmans et notamment donc de
tariq ramadan qui sont porteurs d'un
projet politique
voilà gamal la wii a beaucoup de
mélanges de maurs et les turcs c'est
patrick amador vous mélangez le fromage
une monture égyptien ça n'a rien à voir
ensuite et surtout vous avez fait
référence si luis figo rue discipline
mal donc je vous disais donc ensuite
burqa et voile c'est pas la même chose
ce soir et être mélangés l'urca ces
afghans dans un pays qui sort de ce en
temps de guerre donc ça pays qui a
beaucoup de problèmes à résoudre en
interne et la burqa ne s'exporte pas
ensuite concernant le financement des
cultes
oui il faut financer que pour sortir du
financement extérieur et pour que les
musulmans de france ne sont pas connus
par les kiosques et 10 passes culture
sont ultraminoritaires les musulmans
puissent autonomie c'est quand une mère
écologistes à l'intelligence d'appliquer
les lois de la région a
à ce modèle donc je ne vois pas comment
ai je ne vois pas pourquoi dans une
démocratie la démocratie l'appui direct
qui s'appelle la municipalité vote un
texte à une écrasante majorité est le
premier ministre qui n'est plus dans son
rôle intervient il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas ensuite il n'y a pas de lois
rétroactives en france c'est un pays de
droit si les lois n'existent pas les
appliquent pas existé et existent à ce
moment là on discute aujourd'hui il ya
un vrai problème en termes de stages et
concernant le médian était de 6 pour
finir le mélange des genres je veux bien
qu'on parle de féminisme de droits des
femmes soyez pas trop mal je souscris
mais là on parle de construction de ce
kit gens prier on parle pas de la
politique
toutes les mosquées de france on son
contrôle et un français les services
d'enseignement font leur travail
ce mythe planeta extérieur qui
viendraient et la cinquième colonne
fabriqué par l'extrême droite vous
invite on va donner évidemment la parole
à faouzia gariel je voudrais vous
proposer justement avant d'écouter la
mer fameuse maire écologiste de
strasbourg qui nous parle justement de
valeurs de la république parce que c'est
de cela que faouzia gariel parlais tout
à l'heure c'est peut-être ça qui pose
problème pour certains écoutent et la
mer j'entends que gérald darmanin pose
un certain nombre de questions est ce
que du coup ça signifie qu'ils
s'opposent qui remet en cause le droit
local et et le concordat dans ce cas là
je pense qu'il faut le dire clairement
est-ce que du coup c'est une manière de
dire que le gouvernement souhaite mettre
en cause le concordat et les règles en
vigueur dans notre dans notre région
dans ce cas là je pense qu'il faut il
faut le dire clairement
et si par contre il a des doutes ou des
alertes par particulière concernant le
respect des valeurs de la république
c'est aussi à lui de le dire pour ma
part j'ai fait confiance et aux
responsables locaux antérieur et aux
services de l'état avec lesquels
j'entretiens un dialogue constant sur un
certain nombre de sujets alors
manifestement ministre de l'intérieur a
plutôt une dent contrôle à la deuxième
partir les valeurs de la république que
vous dénoncez également vous aussi fazia
gariel nez ça veut dire quoi selon vous
avec ce que vous nous avez dit hauteur
que les services
l'état un état laïc je le rappelle
malgré tout n'ont pas bien fait dans ce
travail il ya madame je ne pense pas je
pense que je pense que le milieu russe
est une organisation qui est très très
bien structuré qui donne des gages et
qui qui peut se montrer extrêmement
coopérante respectueux sur le moment en
fait il ya quand même un travail de fond
qui fait que aujourd'hui par exemple je
vous donne un exemple l'organisation au
sein du cfcm
la branche marocaine s'est rallié à
l'islam turc distingue conservateur sous
l'influencé justement de cette
organisation du mailing aux russes fois
c'est un destin commun qui se
distinguent conservateur et à l'islam
qui est contre les républiques et
notamment la laïcité et l'égalité
hommes-femmes quoi évidemment ce n'est
pas la construction des mosquées qu'on
critique loin de cela le bonhomme les
musulmans en droit d'avoir des lieux de
culte la question n'est pas là c'est que
ces mosquées là sous contrôle du mil
d'ego russe ils sont indirectement ce
contrôle de la cap et qui les utilisent
comme un soft power pour étendre son
influence en europe sur les communautés
que moi des communes et pictures les
communautés musulmanes gamme alabina
c'est vrai que ben oui parce que ça fait
un peu désordre dans ce contexte que
vous savez évidemment entendu sur ce
sujet voilà prendre précisément la
fédération qui refusent de signer cette
charte sur la laïcité c'est un petit peu
ça fait désordre non son islam de france
par nos parce que non parce que ça pose
problème pas seulement à cette
génération ça inquiète les protestants
c'est là qu'elle est juive si l'on vous
parlait il ya beaucoup de groupes
organisés qui disent quand on commence à
faire des lois si blanc qu on appelle ça
les lois d'exception partir m en fait ce
genre de loi ça rappelle des vieilles
lois dans les années 40 et le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que on parle de
financement ça pose problème
on mélange les genres on dit voilà on
aurait payé laïque donc le droit des
femmes la laïcité c'est pas le droit des
femmes le droit des femmes c'est dans la
constitution française la laïcité c'est
la séparation des églises et de l'état
elle est appliquée elle ne peut pas être
informé de ce point de vue là parce que
ça fait longtemps que d'appliquer en
revanche quand on voit des musulmans
s'organise et se structurer
immédiatement c'est le coup du de la
tête de turc à polisot en lecture
commencée
moi je veux pas faire de mauvais jeu de
mot mime et megan à la vigne je ne fais
pas à côté voilà cette fédération qui
est remise en cause par ce qu'elle
refuse de signer
voilà la la la charte des principes de
l'islam deux chansons bien voilà c'est
pas la seule prime placé que si elle ne
dessine pas à dire la mère l'a précisé
elle doit signer pour avoir la
subvention mais ce qui se passe c'est
que cette opération avait été le
chantier parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'argent donc l'organisation et le soft
power
on se demande où il est ensuite et
surtout parce qu'on a le sentiment qu'à
chaque fois qu'on parle de la communauté
arabo musulmane ou turcot musulmane
ça devient un problème au lieu de créer
des ponts au crédit pour créer des faux
c est pourquoi les autres et pour très
bientôt vas nous sortir que les verts le
parti des verts vont rallier ou non vers
musulmans à force de caricature on
arrive à ça moi je suis pour la loi mais
pas la loi qui n'existe pas et en aucun
cas une loi qui impose et par ministre
l'intérieur qui est en campagne
la question est de savoir faouzia gariel
cette loi sur le concordat
quel exemple le fait de jeter un avis
clairement sur les principes de la
république
oui ou non non elle n'exempte pas du
tout la loi sur le concordat n'est pas
synonyme de deux je dirais d'autonomie
taux de séparatisme vis-à-vis donc des
principes de la république
toutes les organisations culturelles
doivent principe d'un république et en
particulier la laïcité on pas aussi
l'égalité hommes-femmes même si ça ne
rentre pas dans le cadre de la laïcité
c'est quand même le bellego russe oeuvre
pour l'expansion d'un islam je répète
très conservateur très patriarcales et
ce n'est pas conforme aux principes donc
nous la république c'est tout c'est pas
moi qui l'ait en présidant la charte
dans la charte en la charte du mil
légaux russe qui se dit lui-même proche
des frères musulmans lancé que les
frères musulmans sont porteurs d'un
projet politique
gavât la vida on en est pas un premier
scandale en alsace puisque mulhouse
accueille le centre à nous
d'ailleurs nos confrères à christian
chesnot et georges malbrunot et écrit un
livre sur le sujet qatar un espace jeux
des sites ce sont deux journalistes bras
on est de leur bord ou pas il travaille
au figaro mais enfin pour eux c'est une
manière d'enraciner développer l'islam
politique en europe dans des mosquées
qui sont des centres de vie voilà
financé par une ong qatari est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse
c'est encore une forme de sorges de
chasse aux sorcières pour vous le
problème c'est que l'islam politique en
france n'existe pas moi c'était rigolo
qu'on me donne le pouvoir de l'islam
politique
ils sont capables d'organiser des
élections déportés quelqu'un pouvoir ils
sont à capa défiance qui jusqu'au bout
ils font des levées de fonds qui durent
des années ils n'ont pas le soutien des
états d'origine on parle d'islam
consulaire étrangement il est pas
présent et on parle toujours des frères
musulmans comme si c'était un poids
prépondérant en france il n'existe pas
alors si vous êtes capable de montrer
une organisation politique qui va aux
élections et qu'il est passé 10 % à ce
moment là je vous dirais qu'il avait
raison mais ce n'est pas le cas ensuite
concernant les droits des femmes ce
qu'on parle beaucoup de ça l'association
lisa blue droits des femmes le pays le
plus rétrograde au monde en matière de
droit des femmes c'est l'arabie et
bizarrement il n'y a pas trois mois les
critiques jamais ce qui est étonnant ce
soft pas avoir de l'arabie qui achètent
beaucoup de choses n'ai jamais critiqué
moi j'aimerais qu'on ait la même
attitude vis à vis de l'arabie qui est
allié de la france
donc notre sortie qui n'est plus allée
depuis 20 ans arrive au pouvoir
et on entendra sa hausse de 6,6 jamais
eu si jamais le parti tient la porte on
notera celle de tubes avec le parti il
ment on va de plus en plus tentant de de
collusion le régime d'origine
on voit que le problème vient avec son
rôle moi je vous le dis parce que je
suis tant il faut forger le mot de la
fin l'islam politique n'existe pas en
france comme nous l'affirmons games à la
mine a au nom va écouter on peut
toujours voir les choses comme saab et
lycéens politique existe parfaitement
illégaux russe c'est l'organisation
je dirais le mieux structuré qui
bénéficie de financements de la part d'
angles de pays de son pays d'origine
mais aussi de du qatar
je dois rappeler que à l'origine il veut
demander de l'aide au cas par une tant
qu'attaché tories ils ne l'ont pas
obtenue ils ont préféré se tourner vers
des financements locaux des financements
donc nous la mairie ils étaient pas il
était prévu également de demander du
financement du conseil régional à
hauteur de 8% et la communauté
européenne da costa aussi à hauteur du
pur sang que l'islam politique n'existe
pas ça c'est vraiment séduit sophisme
les systèmes politiques existent
parfaitement en france il y a un projet
qui est bien ficelé on le connaît et le
dégoût russe est le meilleur
représentant aujourd'hui de cet islam en
france
merci en tout cas tous les deux gammes
alabina fin nous a gardés elle d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt français
d'avoir exprimé vos points de vue
respectifs